while the belgian road summit is
certainly impressive it's uh china has
absolutely rolled out the red carpet for
the heads of state but also the invitees
which includes some very serious players
in industry to be able to talk about
this and take it to the next level what
about the UK I mean obviously the
Chancellor's over there is there going
to be plenty of opportunity for the City
of London and its institutions to do
deals over there well we certainly think
so and in terms of doing deals over here
that's part of the definition of the
Belton Road which is that it's actually
encompassing 65 countries and the Belton
Road initiative itself may be championed
by China it was an ambition of President
Xi that started in 2013 but we see the
city of London as being the logical
partner in terms of financing for the
Belgian Road and providing professional
services for it so I think that there's
a lot of deals to be had and it's about
us being able to help champion the city
what sort of reception of the British
contingent received from the Chinese
very warm but this is not a new foray
for us we've been working very very
pointedly with the Chinese on
particularly green finance and green and
sustainable finance along the Belgian
road is a topic that is very well
received here it does go along with some
of the high-level principles in the
ambition but it's very very practical
because as I said before a very
long-term strategy means you need
sustainable finance bankable finance but
certainly something that's also green
and that's an engaged topic of
conversation between China and the UK
for many years it's a much cynicism over
there about what China's aims are from
this and this is you know there is one
school of thought that this is all about
exporting Chinese power and influence
around the globe do you get a sense of
that well I am sitting in Beijing at the
moment so perhaps it's not a the best
place for some perspective but certainly
in terms of the talk that's happening in
the corridors you know I think that a
lot of countries look at this as being a
really ambitious way of bringing
countries together not only for the
benefit of China and certainly there is
going to be that but right now global
gross really needs a boost and that
global growth is going to come from
trade so it's not just the initial
infrastructure projects that people are
looking to for expansion for growth it's
also those trade routes that are
becoming reopened and I think that that
is a where there's a real excitement in
the air
India of course is boycotting the summit
it's unhappy about the route that the
road is going to be taking is that being
commented on much it hasn't because I
think that there's just so many other
topics of conversation the widespread
there's over a hundred countries that
are represented here either in terms of
banks or think tanks or NGOs or
multinational Development Bank's so I
think that it has been a very positive
discussion today there was a banking
roundtable that was also very focused on
finance and services obviously something
that we at the City of London believe is
a role that London should be playing a
very very key part in so I think that
the the narrative has been around who is
involved in what countries can really
get involved and cooperate clearly
there's a lot of discussion right now
about protectionism around the world
concerns that even that the Americans
may be driving that to an extent it's
this seen as a counter blast to
protectionism if we can quote the the
speeches that were heard during the
opening ceremony I don't think any of
the speeches didn't talk about this
being an anti protectionism initiative
and I think it was generally
well-received and again I think it does
come back to this opening up those trade
routes and being able to think well into
the future
of course it is very much a Chinese and
Asian trait to not think about next year
or the year after and think about small
time GDP growth you know this ambition
is about decades in the future and it
really is the project of the century as
quoted by some